you know men today accept a lot but
there's just some stuff that you really
can't come back from and I don't know
how you're gonna have a loving
relationship when this is how you're
presenting yourself this is how you're
acting
and and the thing is Brittany like you
you have a son and a lot and and when he
gets to a certain age people are gonna
show him this stuff and I know at some
point there's you you can't undo the
Damage Done but it's like why do why do
we keep going and making it worse like
wearing provocative outfits acting like
this especially especially in public
because that doesn't just affect you it
affects your kid
so you know um again this is women we
are so addicted to attention that if we
don't get the validation and attention
from Men A lot of times we'll resort to
this stuff